President Trump praised Sean Spicer
after the departing White House
spokesman gave his resignation last
night mr. Trump tweeted Sean Spicer is a
wonderful person who took tremendous
abuse from the fake news media but his
future is bright Errol Barnett is at the
White House this morning with more on
Anthony scaramouche II the man who will
now be the president's new
communications director good morning
Errol that's right good morning Anthony
president Trump has found a kind of
kindred spirit in his newly appointed
communications director Anthony Skye
Moochie communicates the way the
President does he uses big gestures
simple language and brings a business
perspective to how Washington should
work I was in the Oval Office with him
earlier today we were talking about
letting him be himself let him express
his full identity I think he's got some
of the best political instincts in the
world and perhaps in history in the
first on camera White House press
briefing since June 29 newly appointed
communications director Anthony
scaramouche II continually praised his
new boss taking questions for more than
30 minutes Skaar Moochie aim to reset
president Trump's public image
I think there's been at times a
disconnect between the way we see the
president and how much we love the
president and the way some of you
perhaps see the president's car Moo
cheese polish debut was in stark
contrast to outgoing press secretary
Shaun Spice's who the day after
inauguration scolded the press over the
size of the audience on the National
Mall this was the largest audience to
ever witness an inauguration period it
quickly became the inspiration for
melissa mccarthy's recurring impression
of Spicer on Saturday Night Live
let me just put this whole Russian thing
to bed once and for all
Trump is innocent how do we know because
he told us so in an interview Friday
with Sean Hannity spice' said it was
time for a fresh dog and after
reflection my decision was to recommend
to the president that I give Anthony and
and Sarah a clean slate to start from a
New York native
scaramouche she grew up middle class on
New York's Long Island welcome to Wall
Street week after stints at Goldman
Sachs and his own investment firm last
year's scaramouche II began hosting a
weekly finance program and making
regular appearances on the Fox Business
Network
it's where early in the 2016 campaign he
was actually a vocal opponent from
Queens County bring it dog he brings it
up every 15 seconds okay one of the
biggest mistakes that I made mr.
president if you're listening I
personally apologize for the 50th time
for saying that they will fall on sky
Moochie and now press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders to defend the president
against the deepening Russia probes
something he refused to discuss Friday
but I just think it's important for me
on my first day standing up here that I
don't go in that direction so I'm not
gonna answer the question now seculow
said he is close personal friends with
president Trump's lawyer Jay Sekulow and
knows very well as a close relationship
with his other key counsel John Dowd so
that will likely bring consistency to
the White House's response to questions
about the Russia investigation but
what's unknown is how he will work with
chief of staff
Reince Priebus Circulo said the two are
like brothers although sometimes they
like to rough each other up once in a
while
Anthony Errol Barnett at the White House
Thank You Errol